[Music]
all right time once again for our
matinee show
this is matinee episode 52 yeah what why
I was laughing cuz I gotta do the show
must my throat sucks it's terrible yeah
he like has lost his voice heaven I fell
asleep I would been drinking you know
and I've had some damn spaghetti sauce
in my stomach and yes I had acid reflux
in it and the damn stomach acid went up
into my voice box and digested my lyrics
it does I digested my own thing
it get better it's a pretty hard it's
real hard for me to talk yeah so yes I'm
one right I'm a run with the show with
this sexy has sex hands voice that's
what I mean I you should like do some
phone sex yeah all right so this week we
are actually doing two movies from 2019
both of which appeared on shudder and
we're also doing something a little
unorthodox
right because we saw the original 1980
Stanley Kubrick movie The Shining on the
big screen in the theater right theater
AMC ran a special show enough yeah it
was [ __ ] packed man we had a good
time yeah it was really cool and it's
not like I said it was my birthday
evening so that we are cool it was a
remastered version but I think it's the
same person that was on the blu-ray yeah
well because I think a new version is
coming out like with new extras and
stuff like that it's coming out October
1st so I guess that's why and plus
because dr. sleep is coming out stuff
like that so we might talk about that a
little bit at the end as well
but as I said the other two movies are
doing our brand-new movies but they are
on shudder and as far as I know didn't
get a theatrical release the second one
maybe did but the first one I don't
think so yeah
so the first one we're talking about is
Hell House LLC three like a fire I
haven't seen the first two yeah yeah
I've just watched it as a standalone and
you don't really have to see the other
two I mean it it it probably does add to
it because certain characters from the
from the first two do appear yeah but
for me it didn't really make
difference which I get to get into that
yeah I mean I do think you will enjoy it
more if you've seen have you seen the
first two but it you know it can be
watched without that like you kind of
but but I think you lose a lot of like
what's going on brah like with all the
little interstitial like clips and stuff
I came into this one had a handy camp
because I really don't like
found-footage Valley a huge fan either
so usually if something's found footage
I just skip it I don't like it but
Jenny's seen them all and Jenny likes
found footage so based on what she's
saying if you like found footage movies
and you like the other ones from this
series you'll like this yeah now I will
say right out of the gate and like I
said I'm not a huge fan of found footage
in general there have been some very
good ones obviously I tend to prefer
found footage movies that are you know
not like just people running around with
a camera although there have been some
good ones like that like wreck and
Cloverfield and stuff like that but I
prefer ones that are done more like a
mockumentary you know like Lake Mungo or
the banjos or something like that which
are usually classified as found footage
even is slightly different now the hell
house LLC series is actually structured
more like a documentary because you know
if you haven't seen the first one and
all three of them are actually on
shudder I think the first one is
available for free on to be if you want
to watch that one you know they're
structured in in the sense that the
first one is a documentary about a
tragedy that happened like with this
group of people who were trying to do a
haunt at this abandoned hotel the
Abaddonn hotel which is in upstate New
York so the third one kind of follows
along with that it's also a faux
documentary it's kind of coming from you
know if you saw the first two I don't
necessarily need to like recount the
first two but you know at the center of
the action there is this abandoned hotel
now at the beginning of the third one
because there have been so many
tragedies that have been recounted in
these mockumentaries like throughout the
series the town of Abaddon has finally
decided that they're going to you know
raise the hotel to the ground because so
many people have died in there there
been
these disappearances and show like that
which they went into in the second one
as well but it so happens that this very
very wealthy philanthropist or whatever
he is I guess he's like a tech
billionaire or something like that named
Russell Wynn actually purchases the
house and one of his things is he's kind
of like you know one of his artistic
hobbies I suppose is producing these
interactive theatre experiences so he
has purchased the Abaddonn hotel in
order to do a an updated version of
Faust now as I said if you've seen
because the first one doesn't really go
too much into the whole satanic cult
angle it's mentioned you know the
legends about the guy that used to live
there and stuff like that the second one
makes it a lot more explicit that you
know the person that once owned this
house
Edgar Tully was like a Satanist and him
and his other Satanist pals are like are
dead but they're still like hanging
around the house and they're trying to
like lure people to the house till I get
souls or whatever so in this third one
it initially seems so so the whole thing
about it is that you know Russell wins
theatre group is you know going through
they've been staying at the house for
three weeks at the point that the movie
starts and they've been like doing
rehearsals of the play like inside the
house and everything and they haven't
really had too much bad should happen to
them and at this point you get another
like a newswoman Vanessa Shepard who
works for mourning mysteries which was a
TV show that they introduced in the
second one although this is a different
host because the host from the second
one disappeared subsequently as many
people had in this hotel so most of the
thing is told from her and her cameraman
you know going through the hotel making
a documentary about the hotel and about
these people doing the Faust play and
she also gives all the cast members
their own GoPros their own cameras and
stuff you know to get them to you know
get footage of their own now I don't
really want to spoil the ending because
it actually went in a direction that I
didn't expect you know which was kind of
like cuz because there's one thing about
one character that you think is that his
motivation is one thing and it turns out
to be something else like I said I don't
really want to give it away I will say
though that I think that of the three
this is probably the weakest one the
first one is obviously the best one the
first one really comes across as an as a
documentary like the acting is very
naturalistic like you get the sense that
these are all like buddies that have
worked together for a long time and
they're putting together this haunt
which I which I found a more compelling
there because I love like I've even
watched documentaries about people that
don't they go around at Halloween and do
these haunts and stuff so I find that
really interesting so in this one the
characters you know they're all actors
though so they're all kind of like
over-the-top and kind of annoying and
then [ __ ] like that and they basically
and I think this was a problem with the
second one too is that they seem more
like actors than like regular people so
you lose a little bit of the
mockumentary feel to it because these
obviously feel like actors in a movie
rather than just regular people being
captured in a documentary you know what
I'm saying so I feel like there was a
little bit of that going on to me to me
to do found footage correctly it
requires a lot of thinking and it does I
think you have to be really careful with
what you're doing because you're really
running the risk of just looking like
some people and a bunch of friends
fooling around with the camera and a lot
of them do turn out like yeah and and
then there's a feeling of that you're in
the haunted house that you pay to go
through in your neighborhood you know
every once every year you know what I
mean and I always get that kind of vibe
and it turned me off from this genre
yeah yeah it wasn't this movie this
movie didn't didn't sour me on it I got
soured on this Chandra a long time ago
yeah so I'm not heaping blame on the
movie you don't mean people like the
other ones you know that they like this
kind of movie then yeah I mean I will
say this one because obviously the first
one was a pretty simple setup you know
there was just like some Inklings of
like the urban legend about the
Satanists and everything like that kind
of mentioned in the first one but I feel
like as the trilogy went on you know
guy that written directed all these
movies Stephen magneti or Kon Yeti he
kind of got like way more ambitious with
the mythology and I think that's kind of
cool because you know it wants to expand
the mythos which you know that's cool
and everything but I'm not really sure
it was entirely successful so that's why
I think the first one is the best one
because it's the simplest it's a most
straightforward it's the most realistic
and like you said I think a problem and
I have this kind of problem with a lot
of found-footage is that you know and I
think a lot of people have this problem
with found-footage is that when you're
making a found footage movie that's just
people filming stuff a lot of the times
it's like you see big [ __ ] monsters
running down the street you wouldn't
keep filming for Christ's sake you would
just drop the [ __ ] camera and run
your ass off you're gonna get eaten
right so it's like so in a way I think
that's why the mockumentary Smuts style
ones like this like um work better
because there's a reason for for people
being filmed you know what I mean and
that's why I like like I said ones like
Lake Mungo which I definitely recommend
if you haven't seen that one which is
like a faux documentary but that was
like actually if you watch it without
knowing that it's a horror movie you
might think it's a real documentary you
know I mean that's how realistic it is
and you know the first Hal the first
Hell house LLC had that as well but I
feel like as it went on it got less
realistic I mean especially as the
mythos got more outlandish I guess I
want to say like it's you know it just
got crazier and crazier there was also a
couple things I didn't like with I felt
like he wanted to expand the mythos to
kind of bring the town of Abaddon like
the other people like townspeople and
stuff and like he wanted to expand out
on that like it wasn't just the Abaddon
hotel there was like other [ __ ] going on
in the town too so I feel like there was
a couple references to that like where
the main character like takes the
newscaster to like this fair ground of a
saying oh that was terrible [ __ ]
happening here even before the Abaddon
hotel was built and stuff but then it
seemed like they didn't really do
anything with that it was just kind of
like one throwaway scene and then they
didn't really mention it again
so I thought that was kind of I could
see what he was trying to do but um you
know he didn't really like follow up on
it which I thought that would have been
a good angle like to kind of expand out
into the town a little bit more but
all-in-all is
not bad there's not it's not as scary as
the first one by a long stretch and a
lot of the scares are very similar you
know you see get the clown is in it
again like the clown prop from the first
one you know it's similar type of thing
where people are filming themselves and
then they'll be like something in the
background and they don't see it and all
this other kind of stuff but there's
really I really only counted like maybe
three scary scenes the rest of it is
just kind of like talking hanging
talking and hanging out like the actors
hanging out which like the first one was
a little bit like that but it the first
one was a lot creepier because it just
ramped up and ramped up and ramped up
whereas this one was kind of like the
live-action gags I thought were pretty
effective they tried some CGI it didn't
really have the CGI at the end of this
looks pretty good
I mean I'm not gonna I would have been I
would have been more happy with some
practical effects just some damn instead
of making a hole in the bottom the
ground open just puts them to do what
they did in the 70s just put a hole in
the ground I have some red lights and
damn fog machine yeah that's all you got
to do or like rewrite it so you didn't
even have to do that do that I mean like
I said usually less is more is
especially something like this where you
know you started out with like a pretty
simple found-footage premise but now
you're trying to get like into like hell
and [ __ ] like that you know that that's
a really fine line to walk and I'm not
sure it was entirely successful at doing
that um it's not a bad movie by any
means and if you and if you really like
the first one in the second one then you
should probably check it out but like I
said I think it's the weakest of the
three the first one is easily the best
one and easily one of the best
found-footage movies so you know your
mileage may vary we'll see how it goes
like some people seem to have really
liked it but most of the reviews I read
said you know it's not bad but it's
disappointing like you know what I mean
and that maybe maybe it would have been
better to have been like rained in some
you know what I mean because he seemed
like he was trying to get like he was
trying to go like way out with the
premise and like build upon the premise
which is good but didn't really get
there I feel like you know so fair
enough but anyway like I said if you
liked him check it out there all three
of them are on shudder right now so you
can watch all three of them in one go
if you're into
you
all right the second movie we're talking
about also in movie from 2019 that just
appeared on shudder very recently is the
Japanese zombie comedy one cut of the
dead yeah real good movie it's not quite
on the same level as train to Pusan it's
a very different kind of movie though it
is it's a trip because the first 20 or
30 minutes of the movie is a movie about
zombies like a low-budget cheap horror
movie all done in one take
yeah there's never any cut it just right
through the whole thing it's a bunch of
cool [ __ ] happens
during that then once the take is over
then it's another movie which is like a
prequel a flashback to how they made
that and that's kind of when the movie
actually kind of begins it's funny as
hell it's a comedy yeah it's definitely
not a horror come I mean its gory but
it's definitely yeah very very funny all
the back flips that these actors had to
do to get that [ __ ] done and it's just
funny as hell it really is it's really
hilarious so it's even though the
English language for title of this is
one cut of the dead if the Japanese
version of the title translates to
either don't stop shooting or don't stop
the camera
so this movie was actually made Believe
It or Not for $25,000 yeah and has
broken a whole bunch of records I mean
at first it only got like a six-day
theatrical release in Japan but it was
so successful that it just slowly
started like expanding outward until
eventually it ended up making like over
27 million dollars something like that
so the first and then it made like a
whole bunch more like worldwide it was
worth that because yeah that first long
cut where they did that whole movie in a
single take that took some planning and
a whole lot of choreography yeah to get
that [ __ ] done right and then they show
you that exact same thing kind of happen
again from the other angles showing you
it was out of frame and and what the
actors were doing before they got into
frame it's it's hilarious it's really
really good I don't think I've ever seen
another movie structured like this it's
kind of like
you know yeah I've seen like other like
meditite movies and other movies that
were like kind of commenting on
filmmaking and stuff like that but this
one is almost like it's like a three
layered film and like I said now I
didn't know hardly anything all I knew
about this was like the two sentence
description that was on shutter that
said it was like you know a director who
was filming a low-budget zombie movie
real zombies showed up and then he just
kept filming because it was like super
realistic and stuff which is true up to
a point but that's not exactly what the
movie is about okay because the weird
thing that happens and this is kind of
like a spoiler alert because you know
I'll just say spoiler alert spoiler
alert in case you don't want to know
anything yeah now if you don't want to
hear yeah so the first it's the first 37
minutes and you're watching this movie
and it's like it's funny but it's like
just really awkward like it's it's just
this really low-budget it's like these
terrible actors and well not terrible
but they're just like not great actors
there's like you know bad zombie makeup
and but they show it that you know that
it's a movie at the beginning because
you see the director and he's coming in
like yelling at the actress and like
saying how she sucks and like he wants
to see real fear and she's not showing
it and all this other stuff and then you
think that then you think that real
zombies start invading this warehouse
where they're filming it made yeah and
so you think that that's how the movie
is gonna go and then 37 minutes into the
movie credits start rolling and it's
like one kind of dead and then and then
there's a title card there's and then
and like I said the first part of the
movie is like super super cheap looking
and it's like you know bad acting and
everything like that and then after that
like there's a really nice like sweeping
shot of a landscape and then it's like
all really nice and yeah it becomes a
full budget it becomes a full budget
movie and that it says one month earlier
and then they're showing like the
director and all the actors and
everything and like the whole lead-up
and it turns out that what the first
part of it was because like I said I did
not know this before I watch the movie
but the first part the first 37 minutes
like the ostensible zombie film that
they're doing I was like I have not seen
a single cut there's there has been a
single cut there's no editing it's just
it looks like it's been all done
take like I noticed it they don't warn
you yeah yeah I didn't know that that's
what I noticed the something's wrong
yeah
well yes I'm wrong they're not ever
changing cameras camera angles there's
no tanks you're just going through the
whole thing live yeah there's no edit it
looks really cool though yeah even
though you could tell it's a cheap
zombie movie and then when it's over 37
minutes in it's not has an hour to go
into a damn mockumentary on how they
made that yeah it's just great so it
turns out like I said so I noticed that
without them telling me
but then when when you go to the actual
like big part of the movie you find out
that what that was that they were
filming was that there was this [ __ ]
zombie channel called and they were
making a one-take yeah cheap zombie
movie yeah and it shows the director
trying to pitch it yeah that's all the
in pitching it trying to pitch it to the
channel it's gonna be done all in one
take and they're looking in there like
laughter there's no for real yeah they
got how all the cast camera crew and
other probs it's the best thing about it
is that so like I said when you're
watching the first 37 minutes and you're
not sure how this is gonna go you know
there's some parts of it where it just
seems very awkward and like the
characters having like these random
conversations like really repetitive and
stuff and I'm like what the [ __ ] is that
about
but like as you're watching the movie
like you find out exactly why that
happened like there'll be some things
where the characters keep her being like
how are you you find
yeah I'm fine wait you already asked me
that and like it goes on for like a
really long time in this kind of like
cringy like the office type of thing and
then you find out later that the reason
they were doing that is because someone
was desperately like off-camera like
going you know something [ __ ] up and
like you have to improvise for a few
minutes but while they fix something
that was going on back here you see why
I wanted a damn zombies look like he was
voguing this cuz he was drunk off his
ass you fine with the crazy [ __ ] you see
in the first part of the first part of
the movie all gets explaining it all
gets explain
and it's just like it's just such a
satisfying like is like I said you see
all this [ __ ] at the beginning and
you're just like what and you're not
entire looks like it's funny but you're
not like entirely sure but then like
watching it like every single thing that
happens like in the first thirty seven
minutes gets explained and it's like
funny as hell yeah it's funny in that
one girl she's you know she's trying to
escape the zombie and a zombie sitting
up there at the top of the stairs and
he's trying to be scary but it looks
like he's dead bogan and [ __ ] and never
attacks he just keeps doing it like I
find out later he's just kind of an
actor that constantly gets having
problems finding work and getting run
off [ __ ] other other other movies
because he's drunk old time and then
yeah he was an alcohol yeah and yeah so
that so it was just all this funny [ __ ]
like I loved the way that they just set
everything up they and he didn't even
care that like if people were watching
it go man this is kind of like a weird
or like a bad movie but then he just
like you have to be very very patient
because he's setting up all the gags
that will all make sense like after you
like the segment because the other dude
had to run so bad he had and he he had
explosive diarrhea zombie didn't make
any sense you like what L left you know
he believed you never see a zombie
trying to leave then when you find out
later what Adam was is that he had to go
bad he pulled his damn coveralls off and
let it fly and the makeup woman comes up
put makeup on him why's going he's did
these embarrassed he's got to get back
in there and make it Mick another part
of the movie this there's no time cuz
it's all gotta be done it's all gotta be
done I'll be today when it's a long time
and you can't [ __ ] it up you know
everybody's in position waiting to do
the show you know which this is normal
just like you know in a stage act yes I
just like do to play I've done a bunch
place when I was in high school and you
know it said all about timing and
everybody in the right spot and
everybody know it so that's what they're
doing it's not really unrealistic
Hey and the thing I like most about this
I mean other than it being funny as [ __ ]
and I really like the stretches like I
said it's like a three-layered because
you know the the live thing that they're
filming at the beginning the story is
that it's a director he's filming a
cheap zombie movie and then real zombies
come but there are no real zombie
zombies there's no real zombies in so
it's just it's all like no that's in the
movie today already baked into the movie
that they're making but then they go
back another layer and they show you how
to happen so it's like it's kind of meta
and shake yeah so it's like you see like
all these people like duck down into the
camera so they don't get on the camera
like throwing blood on people and like
you know [ __ ] happens where unexpected
things happen like one of the actresses
gets knocked out and it's like then she
gets back up and doesn't know what's
going on because she's disoriented and
they have to like take the camera off or
put it on someone got up on further
weakened reconsideration I'd say so it
might be up there with train to Busan so
it may be a difference a very different
kind of movie but it has its own
greatness yeah no way of Greater yeah
it's definitely you can tell that they
cared about what they were that's what I
mean there's they're such an exuberance
yeah to the it's like you can tell this
was somebody that loves filmmaking and
just loves the whole it's it's just such
a joyful movie you know what it means
you get I'm saying like this the vibe of
it it's just a really really fine very
fun movie they understand the genre and
they're kondeh being funny about the
genre yeah not making fun of it
necessarily but they're having fun with
it
yeah it's a very warm-hearted homage to
low-budget filmmaking yeah zombie movies
and zombie movies in like hands of
zombie yeah and a lot of like sniper
fighters that act in zombie movies it is
it's just all over the place yeah it's
just it's a super super fun movie and I
can see why like I said 25 thousand
bucks and this this actually broke box
office records because it made a
thousand times its budget goes to show
you you don't need these big budgets no
if you if you got a bad ass story in a
cast
having fun and believes in the script
that you can make [ __ ] awesome movie
with a short amount with short change oh
yeah make a lot of money off of it yes
you gotta have an angle and you gotta
you got to really know what you're doing
yeah you really not care about the
project and everyone involved in this
definitely did it's a very very clever
conceit it's a very candid also the
thing about it not only has the respect
you know for the zombie genre and for
horror filmmaking and you know just for
the lengths that they'll go to to like
get a good product out you know you can
really feel that in it too but they also
have a lot of respect for the audience
because like I said the first 37 minutes
they were not they were not concerned
that people would think it was just like
a bad movie they were not concerned
about stopping and doing credits in the
middle of it that they were just kind of
like you know what people will figure it
out and well they're not gonna leave
early right so it's like so I'm really
glad that they had the respect to the
audience do that he's like just wait
because everything will be explained
later on and all and everything in the
first 37 minutes it's basically like one
big long gag and all of it will come to
fruition like in the last hour of the
movie as you see like all the [ __ ]
that's transpiring I recommend a movie
to thumbs up I definitely do - this is
super a lot of fun and it's been again
yeah I definitely want to watch it again
- cuz I'm sure I missed some [ __ ] but
yeah so definitely definitely if you're
into horror movies are Shaun of the Dead
anything like that then you will
probably love this so definitely
definitely check this one out it's on
shudder right now Mike that might be the
only place that it's at but I'm not sure
I'm sure you can probably find it
somewhere else maybe Amazon Prime or
something like that but yeah it's
definitely recommended
you
okay for the third movie we actually did
see it in the theater but it's not a new
movie it's an old movie yeah there's not
a whole lot we can say about this as far
as who he goes because everybody knows
it and we've already reviewed it but we
saw this head live in the theater with a
remastered version of it and in a packed
house yes both yeah it was awesome to
see um really mostly what was
interesting is like the differences
between the experiences of watching it
on a TV and watching it on the big
screen and how the audience reacted do
it that's the difference yeah I liked it
I did too and like I was super super
excited when it wasn't outside just
happened to like find out about it just
kind of accidentally when I was checking
the AMC app I think other theater chains
were doing it as well because I think I
read on Facebook that somebody in
another part of the country had another
theater chain and they were playing
aliens soon we're gonna see that one -
yeah that's fathom events they're doing
that on October 13th as far as I know
but yeah so and and so I was so excited
that it was actually you know the
evening of my birthday which was
September 26 and it's like oh my god
they're showing the shining on the big
screen I never got I mean it came out in
1980 I was only eight
I did see horror movies when I was a kid
but that was not one of the ones that I
was actually ever taken at the theater
see so I never got to see this on the
big screen so I was super super stoked
yeah it's good good on the screen the
sound is a lot better oh yeah you could
hear a lot of the chanting and stuff at
the end where the the when the ghosts
are started to show themselves - Wendy
yeah there's a lot of that going on it
Wendy does seem to me she did seem kind
of different on the big screen her
actions kind of see seem a little bit
more over the top you know I mean she
looks kind of over the top goofy at
certain times
there was a younger couple sitting next
to me they were kind of giggling at her
yeah they didn't really get the movie
these are people in their twenties but
they I think they enjoyed it but I'm not
sure how much they understood it yeah
because it seemed to me that like I said
the theater was almost full I think
there was only
of empty seats and it was dead quiet and
I have never experienced that in the
theater ever I don't think it was a
couple people like like when Jack would
say like a funny line or something like
that like when he talked about the
cannibals seeing the cannibals on TV
like he's getting and people laughed at
that it's what they saw on a television
laughs yeah cuz the face he makes but
it's like other than that it was like
super quiet so I feel like most of the
people in the theater were The Shining
fans were Stanley Kubrick fans and so
they had like a lot of respect for the
movie and like I said that's the only
time that has ever happened in the
theatre that I've never heard like
people chattering er yeah well almost
everybody I don't think was in there was
like a hardcore fan they knew the movie
they knew what they were seeing yeah
the couple next to me or a kind of a
Hispanic couple in their 20s and I'm
just kind of using them as a barometer
for the generational differences you
know and the the chick was getting well
kind of freaked out not really knowing
how to take Jack Nicholson
yeah because Jack Nicholson I guess
comes across has really got over the top
yeah to it to a young person when they
see it on the screen she's like what the
[ __ ] she didn't get it in time sounds
like what's up with this guy he's just a
weird [ __ ] yeah he and I should
say we're on a big she's gonna say he
comes across much scarier
I mean he's scary like you know when you
see it on TV and [ __ ] like that point
you see his face like his big huge fan
those [ __ ] faces that he makes it
[ __ ] like that Russians are really
almost kind of exaggerated on a big
screen and I was that was one thing that
I was concentrating on also the score
which you know what it has always been
good but it's really like very prominent
when you see it in the theater but I was
looking at everyone's facial expressions
because I was looking for like new
things to like pick out of the movie
because I was so excited that I got to
see on the big screen and everything and
one thing that I was why I was just
watching all of like his facial
expressions and Grady's facial
expressions and Danny's facial
expressions and it was just like so cool
to see it and and like you said but I
guess because you could see every single
little tick of his face and like every
single twitch of his eyebrow and [ __ ]
like that so he came across as like much
crazier on the big screen that he even
comes across when you see it on
TV and we've been seven seeing modern
movies on the big screen now for what
almost six months solid now yeah
and when you watch this old Kubrick for
the flick on the big screen one of the
things you kind of notices how kind of
crude it comes across in terms of the
edit and the cuts it feels and looks
kind of choppy by today's standards but
it's very Kubrick Ian that's way just
the way they did it then it gives it
kind of a aggressive kind of a sterile
feel to it makes it kind of feel a
little alien in a weird way there's no
way to describe it
there it is different seeing it on the
big screen it feels more like some kind
of an industrial documentary nothing
again that's an interesting with a bunch
more in it yeah cuz it's chopped up and
then there's black screens giving the
date and stuff weighted yeah and the way
it flows it just feels a lot different
on a big screen I didn't notice that the
way I didn't notice that that same kind
of flow on a small screen it's not
strange though because I I mean I know
exactly what you're talking about yeah I
mean that has always been I mean when
you say Kubrick Ian that's pretty much
one of the things they're talking about
his movies do get accused being sterile
Stephen King very famous okay said that
this adaptation that was one of the
reasons he didn't like he called it very
sterile okay unless I picked it up then
yeah I thought maybe it's my imagination
you'd have a real bright screen with a
much snow in it or a pretty interior and
then boom it's gone and it's replaced by
a black screen which with some little
white yeah a white font of some letters
there's not much there and there's
something about going for those big
transition between light and dark
real real abruptly there's no fade yeah
like you just cut it with spare scissors
on the thumb that on the real yeah and
put it together it's not it is very
abrupt but I think it was effective I
think it worked you know I mean it's art
film is art yeah so
he wanted that kind of an industrial
feel something cold and barren yeah and
like I said I think that you know I you
know anybody just read my blog or listen
me talk about The Shining before it's
like I love Stephen King I love the
novel but I think that his criticisms of
Kubrick's movie were very misguided I
think he kind of missed the point of it
yes it's very different from the book
it's not as different as some people
think it is but I mean you have to
respect that Kubrick he has his very own
vision and he took the frame of the
story and did what he did with it and
it's easily I mean not only one of my
favorite horror movies ever easily
probably the best Stephen King
adaptation for sure even though like I
said it's you know kind of loosely based
on the novel but you know the thing
about it like you said about the editing
and [ __ ] like that I think that's one of
the reasons that makes the movie so
unsettling is because you get these
abrupt cuts like that yeah and then
there's these long shots like the shot
of yeah like the shot of or the scene of
um you know Jack Torrance and Grady in
the bathroom where they're talking
there's these long creepy gaps like in
their conversation where they're just
like staring at each other yeah they're
holding eye contact and it looks a lot
looks and feels a lot more uncomfortable
on the big screen it really does I was
like up next to me I could feel them
kind of tensing up cuz it felt felt
[ __ ] very uncomfortable it's an
unsettling yeah and they're kind of
Hispanic and we're now finding out that
the hotel is haunted by a bunch of old
racist people they are when you look at
the crowd they were all white and they
[ __ ] were using racial slurs and [ __ ]
yeah so and they were from another time
yeah and you know they had killed a
bunch of Indians to build that there and
desecrated in an Indian burial ground
and then appropriated all the Indian
stuff and the decor it was about
domination yeah and you could tell that
that's what these ghosts were about they
were just about domination yeah and
you know we went into it in other
reviews the almond says that only the
best people stayed there yep all the
best people
so it was royalty and super rich people
and so they didn't like anybody who
wasn't of their class yeah and they're
ghosts okay
that's some [ __ ] when you think about it
because imagine you deal with some
ghosts that want your soul and then
you're looking down their noses at [ __ ]
because of racial and class differences
yeah it's kind of an alien feeling kind
of an alien concept that you know I mean
yeah the ghost would be classist and
racist
yeah against you it's a trip yeah and I
guess that's yeah that's like an angle
that doesn't really get talked about
when great he's talking to talking you
know to Jack in his eyes is just this
steely cold hatred yeah yeah no you're
dealing with something that's in the
Beyond and it hates you yeah that's some
[ __ ] weird and like I said I think
something that worked really well in
this was that you know and especially
seeing it again on the big screen which
I never got to do before was that you
could really feel the difference between
this stark sterile atmosphere and then
like these grounded characters
particularly Wendy who like you said I
know a lot of people criticize your
parents being like over-the-top and
everything like that but she had to be
like that she had to be vulnerable she
had to be frightened she had to be you
know her and her son because her you
know not only as the hotel turned
against her brother own husband has
turned against her also and so it's just
this really it's just a really good
juxtaposition and I guess so you know
I've always kind of noticed it but it's
like a lot more evident when you see it
like really really big like that and I
mean when we were watching it like I've
seen The Shining probably a hundred
times at least but seeing it on the big
screen like I had you know my free
popcorn for our a-list subscription or
whatever and I'm sitting there
I said well it's this humongous bucket I
said there's no way I'm gonna be able
the third but it's like so I'm sitting
there but it like as I was watching it I
was just like riveted the whole time you
know I knew it was gonna happen I knew
it was gonna but I was just like Roopa
because like you said seeing it on the
big screen it's like the score the
visuals everything like that it just
gives you such an uncomfortable feeling
like in the pit of your stomach and you
don't really get that with a lot of
movies now we actually saw this with our
friend Laurie who had seen it before but
she hadn't seen it since she was a kid
she said impressed she probably been
like a teenager or maybe her 20s when
she had seen it yeah she's a cop yeah
and she was like drinking yeah she had a
blanket like I kept bland sit over at
her she could she comes with a rubber on
and it's just like I kept laughing
because she's like I saw it but it was a
long time ago I don't really remember
and then she has a son who's like 18 or
19 years old now she's in my son plays
the tuba and he plays that [ __ ] from the
shining that like he knows that if she's
like and he will play that show like in
the middle of the night sometimes just
like freaked me out so you know that's
nice yeah for me you know like I said
before I was gonna go back because you
could see their face is so much bigger
and they're you know they're bigger you
see more detail you just kind of the
emotion kind of comes across oh yeah you
know with Lloyd and Grady it's just
these monolithic high-class servants of
evil that just hates you
yeah you can see it a lot better yeah
and I mean and they don't mean that it's
just it's a weird concept that you got
dead people that feel superior to you
that what you did yeah you'd be like
[ __ ] yourself yeah I was gonna say that
one of the things when I was talking
earlier about Jack Nicholson's
expressions and how I could see them so
much better one of the creepiest scenes
I mean there's a whole [ __ ] ton of
creepy scenes in this but one scene that
I feel like doesn't get called out
it's that scene where Danny has gone up
to the gun up to the apartment to get
his fire truck and he thinks his dad is
sleeping but then he looks over and he
sees I'm like sitting on the bed
and that conversation that they had
worse when it's bigger oh that was like
so [ __ ] criminal I've always thought
that was a creepy scene but because you
could see every nuance in Jack
Nicholson's it's correct expressions and
just the creepy way he was like you know
rubbing the kid's arm he's like I would
never hurt you and all this other kind
of very pure oh it's super super creepy
and I was just like my simple I got
chills like watching that scene even
though I've seen it a hundred times yeah
if you get a chance to see this on the
big screen yeah an AMC might play again
I don't know maybe I mean cuz like I
said yeah I guess they did it like I
said cuz dr. sleep is coming out there
they're releasing like a fancy new
blu-ray of course that's gonna be packed
and go you know take your friends it's a
good it's a different experience though
yeah and it was definitely even though
everyone was super quiet which was nice
but it's definitely a different
experience seeing it with other people
like it know the movie and they know the
movie because you're almost like
experienced and experiencing it through
other people's perceptions all know
which I thought was kind of neat so I
you know I never got to see that like I
said fathom events is also doing a lien
on the big screen October 13th for the
40th anniversary came around or
something I haven't seen that on the big
screen since I was a little kid I've
never seen but yeah so seriously do this
it looks great it's like a totally
different experience it's still super
creepy even if you've seen it a hundred
times and it was even more creepy in
some places I thought just because you
could catch like details that you can't
see on a smaller screen but yeah so
definitely do it it was a really good
time
you